I want to live in the spirit world got
him I got him I got my god
I rose back and then did not
general Iroh the other I oh yeah boy
they like that name don't think okay
like various voice actors playing afro
I'm sorry I just got do tickets so oh
yeah
God that was horrible that's just so I
love the way yeah where is this Cora all
along yeah she's more in this past three
episodes a bit more interesting than all
of the episodes we have made yeah I mean
it's I get you could make the argument
that because you know we spent so much
time and you know the sort of dark harsh
you know real world that when you go
into the spirit world it is much more
welcoming you know it feels so warm but
I don't know if you already did that in
season one
you didn't really go the spirit world in
season one no but I mean you could have
watched season one and being like kind
of director I'm gonna be like like I
said maybe even sort of with that first
uh with the backstory of the first
avatar I mean again you could have
spread that out a bit and get a little
bit more balanced a you it still worked
when we go in the spirit world here um
some I ninety percent sure I haven't
checked the Kris but almost 90 percent
sure that's TMS animation which is like
one of my favorite animation man it sure
looked like a oh god about five minutes
and I was do we switch animation yeah no
it's uh I adore that company I think
they do such good work and man what a
perfect episode of bringing in on oh the
ending would that CGI transition from
Korra to the tree with quite - vaatu
nikto be aware is called
um I love the way this world works I
love how something can be near and far
and you can bring it closer it runs
solely on emotion I like remember if you
look for a darkness you will find it is
that what it said something like that
okay oh it was like you had some line
about like you know you bring what to do
it's like Lothlorien you're bringing
what you bring with you so if you bring
darkness if you
darkness you're gonna get darkness what
and I like I like worlds like that and I
like sort of realities and ideas like
that because I think there is so much
truth that true to that in our reality -
that's so much of what you have to put
up with is what you carry with you and
so I like that when she well I like the
bed she transforms into a child I
thought that was really cool I again
just gives my idea how this world works
yeah when Howl's Moving Castle there for
like a minute like yeah I like
transforms he's like younger self and
then she restores part of herself I
really like this so I I did - I for a
second I thought oh this could be
insufferable but I'm like okay no I
actually did it right it's okay yeah and
I like that she had to resort back to
this I mean and as the truth of the
character she's very emotionally simple'
and frustrated and so it makes sense
then this world she would be you know
transformed into a chalice or has to
grow up for like a bear tear of it I
mean it I guess in some ways you could
say it's kind of insulting for the
character cannot even say that anyway
but it it's still worse because it's
still addressing these very simple
truths that even so many adults don't
get so I think it's still very powerful
when you have what your giant metaphor I
mean I line up what it's just like you
know I am you know this little light of
mine I'm gonna let it shine until you
know like you know like you know you
just look scary I was like ah I'm gonna
try that with a Bengal tiger this is
like I'm just gonna walk up to like I'm
gonna hop in the cage is gonna you know
what I do you know but it's a metaphor
so words but I always laugh at that
because it was like I'm just waiting for
to walk up to the wrong thing and be
like you're really pretty on the inside
minute Balzer but no yeah we don't we're
talking about it it's a metaphor balance
is that it's not black and white it's
how you perceive it and and I like that
I like I like I like the love the way
little tea party of course II I row
there is great
it's your unbirthday to it
like if it goes like isn't I referring
to Mary and birthday party hey I'll get
what when they went back into the
library both of us just went oh no no
yeah it's the Great Library and Grandpa
angel visited we were just like oh no oh
no no no no don't go in there aw no this
is a mistake and then we see the owl
that's great Smith I know that boy last
person who is here cut the power that
was dark I mean it's like you know the
guy you know the guy stays there that
was so awesome
babe you know you can assume the worst
but maybe they made a deal maybe Liz
like nope there's just the fucking
skeletons like shit well that's the
thing that I think by by upping the ante
I'm the show but you can get away with
that in this show versus the original
avatar oh yeah I loved that scene I just
burst out laughing it's like but you
still had again it felt so much like
sort of the first three seasons again
with like that great sense of humor
about like how the radio work all this
information about little men in a box
then and then the dog day going walking
away I mean it's that sense of humor but
also that sense of like just real real
imagination real creativity oh my god a
wonderous arm so charming that I forget
what the dragon but the fluffy foot are
you a fluffernutter I'm not owing him
fluffernutter point I knew was it
fluffernutter what a bitch
asshole in a train her yeah um Baskar
yeah yeah I like I like stuff like I
like when she returns the whatever that
Phoenix are dragon bird whatever that
was returns it to the nest and all
transforms into one by me it's like that
was pretty cool it's the strange kind as
a metaphor it was the Phoenix she
becomes whole again and I then kind of
has one of those like Naked Gun 33 in
the third head slapping moments like Shh
like it's like open the portal or I will
take her soul
okay I was like
it's on the other hand on the one hand
it's sort of like I do sir go what would
I do in that situation but it is sort of
like okay so we have seen this yet
Quorra messes up everything itself but
he comes the problem is the problem like
I'm like yeah I would want to save
Jinora but at the same time I'm like you
can't trust that guy I just know he was
gonna just screw you like we go sir and
if you're the old memory does he like he
does technically let it go right that
like doesn't a spirit take her away or
something right now no evil spirit is
only trying to kill Korra yeah like
that's and but what kills me is like she
getting it I feel she does the Phoenix
drags her out of there but I'm kind of
looking it was like well good job
Phoenix when she just grabbed Jinora
like when here now why didn't you grab
tar-like 2.0 and then take him out - I
am I am gonna say this um this is still
the weak part of the show for me I mean
he's got Jinora he's giving her an
impossible choice he's like he's really
badass and when he shows up at the
library is kind of badass but I just
feel nothing for this I have no
connection with tarrlok well we uh
that's the point what a lot I mean it
we've seen him before and it's the first
one light why do we want to see this
well and part of the problem is at least
tarrlok in the first season was sort of
there and established and he had a
steady presence and then he gets taken
out but he comes back at the end you
know he's like oh and he left when he
and he's given death we know what he
wants to do we don't really know why
this guy is helping beautifier which
maybe there were who know Uncas in the
beginning and vanishes we have no
connection with this guy it's like ya
tried to frame the father you know this
and that
Korra resolves that issue and then he's
just in the background like doing
nothing until he just shows up again
spontaneously and I miss like this is I
have no connection with this guy no my
mom was a way better villain oh that
would be fine because Amon disappears -
if they key
yeah there's no business presidents
Caramon that there's no presence - he
just kind of shows me like I my dick
yeah she's kind of generic jerk villain
and I find Varrick more fun to watch
yeah I like it well obviously yeah oh
but I mean just as a character I'm like
more I am more interested trying to
figure out what verax deal is than
analogues at this point I'm almost at a
point where I'm just like you know what
vaatu's the scarier guy you know the
scarier spirit and verax way more
interesting is carrot I even give a crap
about una LOC anymore as far as I'm
concerned he's just a pawn a baktun what
it would have made sense if Varrick was
at you like the guy who was like
bringing back the evil spirit cos really
he's just kind of nutty whatever reason
he would have you just kind of be insane
he's like I like hey I like so what do
you like the Joker IV yeah I actually
could make sense like this other guy
it's like he's kind of logically you
know he has less grand plan things like
just not that interesting we don't know
what the grand plan is either so I agree
I think he's dull he's a dull villain oh
but yeah I loved being in the spirit
world still I love the progression of
the core character I would have liked to
see something a little bit more come of
that of my climax but it's still got a
few episodes 11 and she can redeem
herself in estimates me they feel bad a
last day I did feel really bad when she
says I'm sorry and you know why is my
little girl way out of it I do that was
a great scene that was like Chile yeah I
mean that actually is sort of like a
chewy CNN I found like okay that that
does still work so it's it's just sort
of following in is a much better grasp
performing on sweets and here's the
thing I have a much better grasp of Cora
as a character now after three episodes
than I did and all the lead up into this
and even through some of the first
season which I'm sorry is a problem I'm
like you were able to do this in three
episodes and you've been sitting on it
this whole time and boring me with you
know just the back again forward and
there's like kicking desks and you know
I say I see much more emotion I've seen
much more intrigue in that character
just in that last frame they have of her
looking at Tencent that one carefully
drawn image of her you know just like
terrible and afraid and just looking for
an answer and can't find ants like just
in a walk and yeah to me they just had
not think after that the rat I loved it
with the exception of the lab last one
in the one before you know obviously in
my opinion they were dropping hints of
that in the first season I didn't like
the way the first season resolved itself
where it gave everything back instantly
but she had terror she had to work
through things and I felt like I just
like here - yeah yeah I never power so
she had to use a logically most so we're
going back to where we were sort of in
the first season with what she's working
through but that's part of my problem is
I feel like well we're nearly done with
her words somewhere in the last third of
the the second season and we're going
back to hitting points we already hit in
the first season and it's fun to watch
and I got a better grasp of Cornell but
like what were we doing for the test
yeah if they made they had her more in
the spirit world in this and like her
cut like everything that she did in this
one like even though you can so argue
like whoa yeah obviously be nice
whatever but no I feel that like when
you are more nicer to yourself
understanding of others and stuff like
that it does if it affects not only her
environment but everyone so we went out
and she is entering everyone yeah when
she gets angry everyone else gets angry
too and it's friends and I like that it
does make me realize it and I'm like
maybe somehow they're gonna do something
in this season of the next that will
make me change my mind on this but the
more we're getting closer to getting to
the end of you know this season or
wherever they're going with this the
more I'm realizing that this was
backwards season one should have come
after season two or whatever they may be
doing with season three I'm not sure how
it's working you know but it's like
because she's building up the spiritual
journey in this season you know we've
had nothing of aying this season hardly
anything whereas you know Aang was that
we had flashbacks evading the first one
she meet saying at the end I'm like this
should have been in Reverse they should
have done this season first and then go
to Amman because after you've had this
spiritual journey and make all of these
connections how terrifying would it be
to lose your avatar power to feel like
you've lost
your connection to everything and hello
to two of the show's credit I think
because she had such little emotional
understanding in the first season it was
a greater it was more terrifying her
losing power because it's like that was
kind of related to each other that's
like all she had you know I'm after
going through an emotional journey it's
like well I can still live on after this
I can you know I guess what I feel like
after all of that journeying in season
one we just reverse ourselves back to a
base zero get it yeah no matter what
I've done so I'm just like it feels like
I feel like you could have started
season 1 off with her at a higher avatar
level and then the real threat is Amon
this guy can take away all bending sever
your connection with your other
advertise ourselves you know like I
would have rewritten them on so his
power was even greater so you can sever
that spiritual connection or so or at
least the threat is there like you feel
like this get I feel like it would have
been a better build-up and something
more scary
after going through what is this season
or why not what we said before where her
powers stayed gone a matter of her
powers stay gone and then we started
this season what makes you could
possibly throw control spirits but even
not a lot so journey
what if una luck was showing her how to
get some of her avatar powers back by
doing the spiritual bending yeah that
would have been a way better twist to
get her to follow unalaq along cuz if
Tenzin can show her how to do that like
you know II give a reason why she's
still frustrated too because she has to
go through this emotional journey in the
spirit world would help anatomy is just
like yeah point point being we are back
on track now and this show is really
really good again but yeah I do feel
like we just blew six episodes in the
first half of it ladies and getting here
and I'm just like I know what it was for
but yeah I'm totally glad we're back on
track because this episode was awesome
the previous episode was awesome that
one-hour episode before that was awesome
it's just awesome man
if yeah I think the whole for whatever
six seven episodes before you cut summed
up in two or three yeah you know you did
not need we forget everyone's like
somebody was trying to tell me that the
pilot like didn't have much going on I
was like are you kidding I am great so
much quad in there that I thought yeah
you
do that get two more episodes like that
and instead we slowed to this crawl yeah
and now it's really picking up again
yeah so I yeah I'm curious to see I want
I wanna go bang this fair world we know
or at least we're gonna see it because
what's her name still in there though
can grow back and have another tea party
oh oh so hard water you just make you
feel so good
alright so Monty oh that wasn't our
thing - he actually like he had tea like
it it's a nice a good pic of Atia
actually made so yeah just like give me
that give me that
you now have Michael I don't care it I
fuck me tea during that say because it's
just like the way he talks my tea I
think I'm a tea drinker because this guy
guys are watching but first pcs of the
avatar he just talks about so much
weight you know what this is really
fucking good right one so um yeah we'll
see you guys to the next one